bonsoir sans talent
bonsoir jean todt alors vous êtes tous
les deux les héros d'une histoire
absolument incroyable que vous raconter
dans un livre intitulé blessure d'amour
la force du pardon chez michel lafon
on va raconter d'histoires à raconter ce
qui s'est passé le vendredi 20 septembre
2002 comme tous les matins jean-claude
se lève le premier vers 6 heures
et comme tous les matins depuis des
années il vous apporte son talent votre
café au lit après son départ vous vous
retournez sur le côté droit face à la
porte vous rend dormait et soudain
quelque chose explose dans votre tête
vous est traversé par une décharge
électrique d'une violence extrême
vous réalisez pas tout de suite qu'un
coup de feu a été tiré et que vous êtes
blessée à la tempe gauche
un peu plus tard votre mari jean-claude
s'approche de vous et vous dit c'est moi
c'est moi j'ai des problèmes
alors en fait face à une situation
financière inextricable
jean-claude vouliez vous supprimez après
avoir tué votre femme
mais la première détonation à alerter
votre fils et vous n'a pas pu aller au
bout de votre acte quand les pompiers
arrivent vous dit chantal vous n'allez
pas mettre mon mari en prison puis vous
sombrez dans un grand trou noir
et quand vous vous réveillez le médecin
vous explique que vous êtes aveugle
on va vous demander à voir votre mari
vous explique que c'est impossible
vous ignorez qu'il a été mis en examen
vous jean-claude dès les premiers jours
vous savez que quand elle restera à
voeuil gelé a pris au bout de deux
semaines et pendant deux semaines je ne
savais pas si mon épouse était encore
vivante ou pas on a laissé complètement
j'étais même d'ailleurs le soir même de
comment de ma mise en garde à vue était
hospitalisé d'office en psychiatrie
étant donné que je sais pas j'étais dans
très grande détresse psychologique et
même temps dans mon comportement
inaltérée cometti 90 quoi bon et puis ça
va je remercie de votre invitation pour
surtout pour chantal mais pour moi c'est
j'aimerais être sur ce plateau pour
d'autres circonstances rien comprenez
c'est c'est quelqu'un c'est très
difficile à vivre
qu'est ce qui vous a amené à sac avec et
la situation qui vous a amené à
commettre ce geste c'est à dire de
supprimer votre femme avant de vous
supprimez comment est ce qu'on peut en
arriver là je sais pas c'est bon j'ai
toujours c'était comment c'est très dur
dans l'année 2000 à coup au deuxième
semestre 2001 et puis bon vous savez
qu'on a très vite en profession libérale
faire tout de suite un audit de ce qu'on
va avoir à chaque comme charges à payer
pour l'année suivante
et quand je me suis aperçu que de tout
ce qu'ils avaient à payer et puis les
retards que je prenais honorant les
échéances barre de tout ce qui est
organisme de professions libérales
l'urssaf les caisses de retraite les
assurances maladie les assurances
chantier tout je m'apercevais que vu le
montant qu'il fallait déjà rien que pour
2002 à payer que je voyais pas les
honoraires qu'ils allaient rentrer
puisque les colères étaient bien là mais
rien ne sortait puisque pas de
financement des problèmes avec où je
citerai pas des administrations des
dossiers ne sortait pas d un dossier
qu'on m'avait promis et qui est parti à
notre architecte ou ailleurs
sur le tout le travail ce qui fait que
déjà fin 2001 je me suis retrouvé à ne
plus avoir de rentrer d'un horaire et
avoir toujours où ces charges qui tombe
c'est un impôt bon et je le dirai
puisque je pense que mes collègues qui
m'entendent dans la profession puisque
j'étais architectes il me fallait déjà
pour 2002 six cent quarante cinq mille
francs à voir voir avoir ce prix un seul
centime pour commencer mois à vivre
en fait vous êtes des gens du nord oui
j'ai commencé les aciéries comme comme
apprenti ajusteur peur et puis vous êtes
devenu architecte à la force du travail
mise 7 élevé socialement tout seul avant
de vous installer à votre compte et puis
un jour vous apprenez comment dit que la
banque couple le robinet et trois jours
avant les fusées de coincer coincé et
puis vous en parlez pas à chanter allah
ce moment nos jeunes j'ai jamais c'est
là justement où si je peux passer un
message à d'autres personnes qui
pourraient être dans la même situation
que je l'étais et bien c'est de d'éviter
de de croire que manger c'est peut-être
été naïf je voulais toujours protégé mon
fiston les poulains et leur éviter cette
pas dire c'est pas de leur bien
croyez-moi ce cette déchéance
je me suis dit ouh tout l'aboutissement
de toute une vie j'ai dit mais comment
tout perdre
je savais que j'allais perdre ma maison
est bon mais le créancier qui avait
refait de près de la maison voulait la
mettre en vente aux enchères dont tous
ces huissiers qui arrivait et croyez moi
un pied alors là c'est une multitude 1
sont là ils vous connaissent pas
c'est tout ce qu'ils essayent pas de
comprendre ont donc je suis rentré que
j'arrivais pas à dire vous voyez les
choses
j'arrivais pas ouais je me suis renfermé
sur moi-même
et puis on essaie à tout seul oui depuis
plusieurs mois je vous dirais que je
dormais plus la nuit genre des fois
j'allais lui même elle aime à la
télévision pour avoir une présence mais
je regardais même pas le film
jeu et ça m'arrivait même comment cette
idée va germer dans votre esprit vous
vous dites y'a plus de solutions je vais
pas y arriver je suis coincé disons que
avant les dernières vacances 2002 dont
j'avais quand même réussi à mettre un
peu pour dire de pouvoir partir parce
que monsieur zyl peut être que la
prochaine on pourra plus du tout partie
dont j'avais toujours espoir
bon alors on est donc parti en vacances
mais des gens moi mais même avant les
vacances
je m'étais dit mais je ne fous travers
je ne supprime et je partirai et puis
avec le temps
bon donc je ne voudrais pas mettre la
religion sur ce plateau mais nous sommes
croyants on avait été à comment a
ordonné c'est ça en ariège et après
auprès d'eux à des prêts de lourdes donc
j'ai toujours espéré j'ai pas cru au
miracle parce que je crois que dieu il
ya bien d'autres choses à penser que
c'est toi le ciel t'aidera toi voilà
non il faut pas commencer à dire de moi
j'y crois pas du tout moi c'est nous qui
devons ce faire il arrivait donc j'ai
toujours espéré et puis je suis rentré
de vacances
et là ça pour moi ça a mûri c'est
vraiment j'avais vraiment envie de
partir et puis mais comme chantal m'a
toujours du jour et même avant que
j'étais installé quand j'étais salarié
on n'a jamais rien fait sans note c'est
que j'allais fermer chantier chantal la
compagnie je faisais quand même des
déplacements assez important on partait
du matin au soir les resté dans la
voiture elle bouquiner à l'écouté la
musique on a toujours été ensemble et
j'ai jamais vraiment trouvé le moment
d'être seul ce qui fait qu'il est mon
mon idée reculer toujours
et puis alors là c'est quand vous
décidez de me supprimer
oui pour vous les naturelles de
supprimer chantal en même temps annonce
et j'avais pas l'idée de supprimer le
chanteur est ce qu on a dû tout c'était
moi et puis avec le ceta virus
ce manque et qui m'a appelé qui m'a dit
monsieur landry c'est tout on vous suit
plus en couple et robinet alors je me
suis vu avec des échéances impayées tout
ça le prêt de la maison et là quand il
m'a appelé le 15 et 16 septembre 2002
quelques jours avant les faits il m'a
dit bon vous bloque tout nous avons au
contentieux ou c'est tout alors lâché
j'ai dit je vais et puis j'ai dit non on
a toujours est ensemble
bon ben je sais pas j'ai peut-être
préjugés de de dire ben voudra partir
avec moi et puis je dire on va partir
tout galop j'ai toujours dit à mon gamin
il ya 17 ans on n'a pas beaucoup de
familles mais il sera certainement
recueillis il ya d'un côté comme de
l'autre
bon je ne discuterai pas sur ce sujet
mais ça s'est pas fait et puis je me
suis levé vous ce fameux matin je savais
pas je savais pas si j'allais me puis je
sais pas vous réagissez comme ans quand
quand vous apprenez que chantal ne porte
pas plainte finalement et qu'elle a
décidé de vous pardonner
ben je les suis quand même je n'ai pas
su tout de suite j'ai passé tout de
suite
moi je vous dirais que dans
l'incertitude comme pendant deux
semaines je ne savais absolument pas si
chantal était encore de ce monde
bon moi je vais bien vu partir à dans la
coquille ou les pompiers l'ont emmené le
samu n'ont m'a pas dit on m'a dit elle
est inconsciente à ce moment là bon ben
j'ai dit je savais pas et sait comment
par la visite d'un ami prêtre qui est
venu de me donner de nouvelles bon et
puis après peu de temps j'ai plus le
droit de rencontrer non plus un jeu
suite à un contrôle judiciaire alors au
procès chantal vous avez déclaré j'ai
compris son acte et je lui pardonne je
laime et je veux vivre avec lui le mal
d'être séparé de jean-claude serait pire
que la cécité
vous lui en voulez pour ce qu'il a fait
à aucun moment où il y en avait voulu
peut-être sur le comprenais pas j'ai pas
compris je comprenais pas mais je non je
ne peux pas dire que je lui en ai voulu
je pleurais tous les jours à l'hôpital
parce que je voyais jamais arrivé je
comprenais pas ou qui ne venaient pas je
comprenais pas non franchement non j'ai
pardonné oui ça c'est sûr j'ai compris
son geste
parce que surtout encore encore plus
maintenant parce que quand je suivais
tout ce qu'il a portés tout seul comme
ça vous dit mon pardon n'est pas une
énigme c'est simplement un acte d'amour
mais je comprends ça je comprends que il
a dû perdre les pédales
acculé à des difficultés comme ça et
porter ça tout seul sans pouvoir se
confier à qui que ce soit mais je
voudrais quand même souligner qu' on a
une il est épaulé pendant des années par
un ami prêtre qui avait baptisé notre
fils et je pense que s'il avait été
seulement de les choses se serait pas
présentée de cette façon ça j'en suis
persuadé dire persuadé je trouvais pas
paolo que c'est une histoire
extraordinaire cet homme qui est qui et
voilà qui est broyé par le système
public y c'est cet homme qui s'est élevé
tout seul qui était ajusteur qui a
travaillé jour et nuit pour arriver être
architecte il s'installe à son compte il
y arrive
au début ça marche bien mais très bien
très bien vous achetez une maison ça
donc voilà c'est cet homme se retrouve
brisé par par le service avait plus
comment vous en sortir
vous lui tirez dessus elle vous pardonne
et aujourd'hui vous êtes lié
éternellement je savais ce que chantal a
fait bon c'est vrai c'est
moi je crois que bon il ya la foi qui
qui à perdre qui permet à chantal de de
vivre cette situation de ces sites et le
pardon chantal j'accepte mais
actuellement
moi je ne pardonne pas je peux pas me
permettre je ne peux pas faut savoir
donner
vous savez chérie je vais qui est un peu
une situation très compliquée je ma
famille aussi
quand j'étais gamin quand je donne
adolescents mais par un dans un acte
désespéré d'amour mois interne y aider à
nos pratiques et tricot et après quand
j'ai sorti un match où les modèles vous
n'avez pas donné votre vos parents mais
ça passe pas même pour les partants
l'amour et au delà des to on comprend
que tu es un geste désespéré d'amour
n'est ce pas comme mes parents ils ne
l'ont pas faire du mal à moi mais savait
pas quoi faire comment marseille devant
ça passe
au delà je pense donc je crois que c'est
un geste d'amour oui ça c'est sûr que
jean claude a sauvé la vie parce que si
elle avait porté plainte vous seriez en
prison aujourd'hui
ce sera en prison et pour de nombreuses
années je sais que je risque puisque le
procureur général avait au début on
m'avait dit c'est la perpétuité et lui
et si chantal n'étaient pas intervenues
je prenais 20 ans voilà donc je serais
sorti
1 78 ans de prison à l'âge de 78 ans
mais vous savez tout à l'heure on a
rencontré une personne qui qui me posait
la question est ce que vous sentez
comment redevable vis-à-vis de chantal
non je me sent pas redevable ce que je
fais pour chantal maintenant les
dénoncer ces cités c'est de l'amour
c'est tout c'est bien ça c'est pas
comment c'est pas de la pitié que j'ai
pour chantal pas du tout moi c'est comme
je me répète c'est arrivé à me pardonner
et ça je me lève le matin je travaille
avec la journée je me couche avec nous
ce soir
et oui j'étais d'accord mais quand savez
quand je vois chantal assises
un fauteuil et que moi je m'active à
faire un peu les tâches ménagères tout
ça et quand j'ai vu mon épouse qui
entretenait notre maison on avait avalé
on a eu une petite maison un qui était
très bien mais entretenues parfaitement
9 un jardin qui était magnifique avec
des fleurs partout qu'elle entretenait
elle tendait la pause faisait tout bon
elle était bénévole a le rang des
services et moi je ne peux pas accepter
de lui avoir enlevé tout ce à quoi
maintenant parce que vous savez si si je
pouvais dire à aux personnes qui
savaient au bout dans notre département
dans nord bon j'ai des problèmes on a pu
y aller un peu excusez moi des termes
c'est peut-être un peu cru mais je
prends une bonne cuite
oh et puis pendant que j'ai pris je me
semble et puis j'oublie mes problèmes
mais le lendemain matin quand tu te
réveilles tu te réveilles avec et moi
j'ai cru qu'en en faisant cet acte en
voulant partir donc peut-être que serait
abouti je sais pas si manuel n'était pas
intervenue que chantal et bien ce geste
avait été fatal je serai certainement
plus là non plus aujourd'hui
bon ce serait terminé les voyons
maintenant eux c'est encore plus
dramatique que ce qui avait après c'est
vraiment posséda mans pour moi c'est
dramatique vous vivre avec est calé
semaine les gens dans cette situation
quel est ce monde
en tous les cas vous donner une belle
leçon d'amour chantal
c'est le soir
les soins
jean claude a eu un grand amour aussi
parce que il a fait ça aussi parce qu'il
voulait pas non plus me laisser seul
devant des difficultés que je ne
connaissais pas c'est ça surtout je
pense que j'aurais eu plus de mal à
pardonner si c'était supprimés seuls il
nous laissait tous les deux emmanuel
moire sens avec des difficultés comme ça
qui m'arrivait alors là vraiment
j'aurais trouvé ça plutôt lâche
or son geste je comprends tout à fait
parce que il a fait ça par amour et non
pas pour ce pour me supprimer non je
voulais y avait trouvé cette solution le
plus simple étant donné ce qui est
terrible c'est qu'on pense au film de
costa gavras qui s'appelle le couperet
c'est à dire qu'à un moment la violence
sociale est tellement tellement dur que
les gens à vienne à apprendre des
flingues quoi ouais soit pour se tirer
dessus soit pour tirer sur les autres
mais qu'à un moment la violence sociale
est insupportable dans ce monde si cette
situation même si j'avais un pire ennemi
je souhaite pas ouais on peut pas
souhaiter ça quelqu'un est ce que vous
croyez que le fait d'avoir été au départ
ajusteur d'être un être un pauvre
ouvrier fils d'ouvrier fait mais j'avais
voulu s'élever dans la société d'avoir
voulu devenir un architecte une
profession libérale
elle souffrait que tête vous n'aviez pas
les armes pour pour vous battre dans ce
monde là bas
écoutez moi je on m'a fait le reproche
que je n'avais pas comment cette faculté
d'avoir ce relationnel
ouais c'est à dire dans les dents en
fait la particularité à vous voilà non
non non je bois c'est bon j'ai jamais
été j'ai jamais invités qui que ce soit
mais simplement parce que je me disais
j'ai du travail parce que où je le fais
bien où l'on m'en donne c'était comme ça
je voyais pas pourquoi il fallait
commencer à les s'attabler pas dans deux
trois heures ou et puis finir dans un
bar après pour habiter parce qu'il donne
moi du travail pit jeta villes vont
manquer les les clés de ce monde là
voilà sacha vais pas faire un chantage
jusqu'au bout si vous avez quelque chose
à dire à jean claude avant de me séparer
je t'aime
[Musique]
m
lonnie mai
ces pluies ce monsieur lavaud
des corrections de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus